ok dann können wir beginnen der
regierungssprecher sagte wir dürfen auch
vor der zeit schon anfangen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich freue mich
sehr sie im namen der bundesregierung
hier zur pressekonferenz zur vorstellung
der korona vanek begrüßen zu dürfen
gemeinsam mit den bundesministern und
bundesministerin professor braun
bundesminister sparen bundesminister
seehofer und bundesministerin lamprecht
dem präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts herrn professor dr
villa und dem vorstandsvorsitzenden der
deutschen telekom ag herrn tim höttges
und herrn dr müller mitglied des
vorstands von sap freue mich sehr auch
wenn sie im vorfeld schon der ein- oder
angriff und ihnen gesagt hat dass es ein
sehr großer bahnhof mit fünf
kabinettsmitgliedern und auch der
wissenschaft und der wirtschaft
normalerweise würden staatsgäste so
begrüßt werden dass wir trotzdem heute
hier ein gemeinschaftsprojekt aus
wirtschaft wissenschaft und politik
ihnen vorstellen dürfen
eine app die uns helfen soll gemeinsam
den kampf gegen die weltweite pandemie
zu führen die noch andauert wo wir aber
mit geschlossener schulter gemeinsam
entgegentreten wollen
ich darf ihnen jetzt die einzelnen
rednern der reihe nach aufrufen und dann
im anschluss können sie fragen stellen
und beginnen wird herr bundesminister
professor dr braun
er hat das wort ja einen schönen guten
morgen
seit heute ist die korona waren app für
die beiden wesentlichen betriebssysteme
von smartphones verfügbar
das haben sie alle gemerkt das ist nicht
die erste corona app weltweit die
vorgestellt wird
aber ich bin ziemlich überzeugt es ist
die beste sie herunterzuladen und zu
nutzen das ist ein kleiner schritt für
jeden von uns aber ein großer schritt
für die pandemie bekämpfung und dabei
können die bürgerinnen und bürger auf
höchsten datenschutzstandard und mit
größter datensparsamkeit vertrauen und
sich auch auf einen hohen
sicherheitsstandard verlassen wie man
hier unschwer sehen kann es handelt sich
um ein projekt der gesamten
bundesregierung und es hat eine breite
vorgeschichte ich möchte zunächst den
erst initiatoren danken das war die
initiative pt
die sich auf den weg gemacht hat für
deutschland eine und für europa eine app
auf dem bluetooth standard auf den weg
zu bringen
das war eine grundlegend neue idee die
uns von einem sehr großen problemen
befreit hat nämlich vorher empfehle an
gps lösungen bedacht die natürlich mit
bewegungsprofilen verbunden sind und der
wechsel auf die bluetooth-technologie
hat dazu geführt dass wir heute eine app
vorstellen können die sich völlig
losgelöst von der frage des ortes und
damit der daten sparsam ist und damit
ein sehr hohes maß an datenschutz
gewährleistet so wie wir uns das in
europa vorstellen
ganz besonders bedanken möchte ich mich
dabei der fraunhofer gesellschaft weil
sie es ermöglicht hat genau diesen hohen
diesen neuen bluetooth standard auch
technisch so weiterzuentwickeln dass wir
heute eine gute messmethode in dieser
app haben die uns die abschätzung der
zeit dauernd der entfernung in der sich
ein möglicher epidemiologisch relevanter
kontakt aufgehalten hat er sehr präzise
ermittelt im verhältnis zu dem
referenzmodell nämlich unsere erinnerung
wenn wir vom gesundheitsamt nach einer
infektion gefragt werden
ich möchte mich bedanken bei jens spahn
und dem robert koch institut das robert
koch institut liefert sozusagen die
logik hinter dieser corona waren app und
verantwortet sie insgesamt da steckt
sehr viel arbeit dahinter das risiko
richtig einzuschätzen das was wir
sozusagen als lebensweisheit aus
ärztlicher erfahrung bisher als
verhaltensregeln geben dann in eine
risiko algorithmus umzusetzen war eine
große leistung ich bedanke mich bei
horst seehofer und dem bundesamt für
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
die menschen müssen darauf vertrauen
können dass diese app sicher ist dass
sie also veräußerungen einfluss
geschützt ist und auch dort wurde tag
und nacht gearbeitet bedanke mich bei
bundesministerin lamprecht und
dem bundesbeauftragten für den
datenschutz die von anfang an daran
mitgearbeitet haben dass wir ein sehr
vertrauenswürdiges datenschutzkonzept
haben dass es weil wir uns unterwegs
sehr auf den weg gemacht haben zu sagen
dass diese app absolut freiwillig ist
jeder bürger kann selber entscheiden ob
er sie nutzen möchte war es natürlich
eine wichtige voraussetzung dass wir
größtmögliches vertrauen schaffen und
deshalb haben wir eine sehr daten
sparsame variante der äbtissin heute
vorstellen was genau das gewährleistet
ich möchte mich auch bedanken bei der
helmholtz gesellschaft die uns auch sehr
unterstützt hat eben bei allen
sicherheitsbelangen so dass wir die app
heute so vorstellen können und nicht
zuletzt bei sap und der deutschen
telekom
denn sie haben vor einigen wochen ja
mitbekommen es gab eine große diskussion
genau um die frage wie daten sparsam ist
die etwas bekommt der bund an
informationen
wir haben jetzt uns für die dezentral
und damit die daten sparsamste aller
lösungen entschieden und in dem zuge
brauchten wir auch dann ein neues und
zugkräftiges projekt management team das
haben wir in sap und telekom gefunden in
den letzten wochen haben wir sehr sehr
intensiv zusammengearbeitet und so
können wir diese app heute präsentieren
was auch für mich ein positives erlebnis
innerhalb der vorstellung ist es die
tatsache dass wir von anfang an auf
transparenz gesetzt haben auf open
source und wir haben sehr viele
wir haben sowohl den code als auch das
datenschutzkonzept als das gesamtkonzept
öffentlich dargestellt und uns und
unsere entwickler hatten sehr viel
arbeit damit die vielen hundert eingaben
aus der it szene aus start-ups und
ausländer aus sich anzusehen und vieles
auch einzuarbeiten was von dort aus sie
als hinweis kam
insofern war open source an der stelle
von uns nicht nur ein instrument der
transparenz sondern auch wirklich der
qualitätssicherung und die vielen
ehrenamtlich und unentgeltlich sich in
den code vertieft haben
auch den gilt unser herzlicher dank und
so präsentieren wir ihnen heute eine
corona waren app die glaube ich
einzigartig ist und die darüber hinaus
durch die anbindung von laboren im
menschen ein echter sie nutzt einen
echten mehrwert bietet nämlich der
zügige zugang zu einem test und einen
schnellen hinweis auch auf sein
testergebnis
vielen dank ja vielen herzlichen dank
bevor jetzt bundesminister spannendes
wort bekommt wollen wir ihnen noch einen
kurzen film zeigen wie die app denn
eigentlich funktioniert mit der korona
vanek können sie mithelfen
infektionskette zu unterbrechen mit
minimalem aufwand dafür aber mit
maximalen datenschutz
die korona waren etwas nicht wer sie
sind
aber sie kann sie begleiten damit sie
sich und ihre mitmenschen besser
schützen können
immer wenn sie einem anderen nutzer
begegnen tauschen ihre smartphones
automatisch verschlüsselte zufalls codes
aus diese zufalls codes sagen den handys
nur dass sich zwei menschen begegnet
sind wie lange das dauert und wie groß
dabei der abstand war sie verraten aber
weder namen noch standorte der andere
nutzer wird also nie erfahren dass sein
smartphone mit ihrem smartphone einen
code ausgetauscht hat ihre identität
bleibt geheim
nach 14 tagen werden die codes vom
smartphone gelöscht hat sich ein nutzer
nachweislich infiziert kann er seine
eigenen zufalls codes anonym
allen anderen nutzern zur verfügung
stellen auch ihnen ihre app findet in
code den ihr handy damals mit dem
smartphone desinfizierten ausgetauscht
hat und informiert sie dass sie kontakt
zu ihm hatten gleichzeitig gibt sie
ihnen konkrete handlungsempfehlungen
auch sie bleiben dabei jederzeit anonym
corona zu bekämpfen ist ein
gemeinschaftsprojekt auch sie können
einen beitrag leisten
mit der korona waren app schützen sie
sich und ihre mitmenschen
vielen dank das wort hat der
federführende minister
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
ja liebe doch wer meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir sind sehr froh
darüber dass es gelingen kann heute
ihnen die app vorzustellen weil da
steckt wahnsinnig viel arbeit drin auch
das finde ich muss man immer wieder
deutlich machen weil wir höchste
anforderungen gestellt haben bei
datenschutz datensicherheit aber eben
auch etwa bei der frage dass die
batterie nicht schnell ist wie das in
anderen europäischen ländern das erleben
ist und dass die technologie dahinter
gut ist das ist auch gute
ingenieurskunst das ging nicht nur um
wichtige kunden sondern auch um
ingenieursarbeit und wir sind im kosten-
und zeitplan heute mit ihnen eben bei
der vorstellung dieser app und der film
hat gerade sehr gut die grundzüge der
app erklärt sie war die anonymität das
ist wichtig sie ist freiwillig in jeder
hinsicht freiwillig ob man sie
herunterlädt freiwillig wird man sie
dann überhaupt einschaltet und die
bluetooth messung einschaltet sie ist
freiwillig in der frage ob man nach
einer positiv testung sich dann
entscheidet andere zu informieren und
sie ist auch freiwillig in der frage ob
jemand der informiert wird über einen
möglichen risiko kontakt und einer
risikosituation wie der oder diejenige
dann damit umgeht sie gibt also
empfehlungen keine anweisung und das ist
glaube ich noch mal für die einordnung
auch sehr sehr wichtig wichtig ist auch
immer wieder der hinweis diese app ist
kein allheilmittel sie ist kein
freifahrtschein aber sie ist ein
wichtiges weiteres werkzeug bei der
eindämmung der pandemie bei der
eindämmung dieses virus warum sage ich
immer wieder ausdrücklich sie ist kein
allheilmittel kein freifahrtschein weil
es wichtig ist dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger am ende mit nehmen diese app
ersetzt nicht vernünftiges verhalten und
aufeinander acht geben
das virus ist immer noch da das sehen
wir an vielen ausbrüchen auch jeden tag
an verschiedenen stellen
lokal und deswegen bleibt es auch mit
dieser app weiterhin wichtig abstand zu
halten in bestimmten situationen alltags
masken zu tragen hygieneregeln zu
beachten aber und das ist der
entscheidende unterschied und die neue
qualität die app kann helfen
kontaktpersonen von infizierten
schneller zu wahren als das bisher
möglich war und jede stunde früher
warnung über eine infektionsgefahr ist
ein gewinn beim kampf gegen dieses virus
hören ja aber und angefragt passt die
app eigentlich noch in eine zeit wo
gerade auch die infektionszahlen zu
niedrig sind und ich würde sagen sie
passt sehr gut gerade in dieser zeit wir
haben gemeinsam viel erreicht wir sind
aktuell stand heute mit den
infektionszahlen in einer guten lage
aber wir wollen uns diese lage ja auch
erhalten das erreichte sichern und dabei
leistet die app einen wichtigen beitrag
gerade in einer phase wo wir jetzt ja
zug um zug in den bundesländern sehen
und entscheiden miteinander dass es mehr
und mehr lockerungen gibt und es wird
jetzt mehr und mehr kontakte auch geben
ob auf der demonstration im zug im bus
im öffentlichen leben wo es auch anonyme
na ja sozusagen gibt wo man nicht weiß
wer ist eigentlich der oder die neben
mir wenn ich vorgestern mit einem freund
essen war dann erinnern nämlich einen
zweifel daran wer es war und dass es
stattgefunden hat wenn ich in einer
demonstration war
wenn ich in einem zug gefahren bin kann
ich nicht immer wissen in aller regel so
gar nicht wissen wer eigentlich der die
andere mitfahrende ist und gerade in
solchen situationen macht die apple
entscheidenden qualitativen unterschied
weil wir eben damit auch diejenigen
informieren können über ein mögliches
infektionsrisiko wenn ein mitfahrender
positiv getestet wird die wir sonst nie
hätten informieren können und das macht
die kontakt nachverfolgung und das
unterbrechen von infektionsketten eben
deutlich einfacher deutlich schneller
deutlich besser das gilt im übrigen auch
in der urlaubszeit
ja sie ist noch nicht arbeiten wir auch
dran in der frage europäisch alles in
den schnittstellen abgestimmt aber es
gibt ja einige länder da sind auch viele
deutsche gleichzeitig im urlaub da macht
es dann schon ein unterschied und viele
sind in deutschland im urlaub und es
macht einen unterschied für die rückkehr
aus dem urlaub auch das haben wir in den
monaten erlebt das ist auch da wichtig
ist schnell andere zu informieren wird
es situationen geben wodurch die app
auch mal ein fehlalarm ausgelöst werden
kann ja das können wir nicht zu 100
prozent ausschließen
das ist wahr aber auch bei den
gedächtnis- protokollen die heute
angefertigt werden wenn sie gefragt
werden vom gesundheitsamt von den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern dort
erinnern sie sich eigentlich noch wen
sie in den letzten zwei wochen so alles
getroffen haben wo sie einen näheren
kontakt hatten auch dort ist nicht immer
100 prozent genauigkeit was die app
macht ist zu informieren und einzuladen
sich testen zu lassen und mir ist lieber
einen test zu viel als einen test zu
wenig auch das ist eben wichtig um die
das virus weiter einzudämmen und unter
kontrolle zu halten abschließend ist
wichtig dass die app wie eigentlich
alles im digitalen leben als lernendes
system angelegt ist wir wollen jeden tag
auch aus den rückmeldungen bekommen
heute morgen schon viele rückmeldungen
wie sie sicherlich auch ich freue mich
sehr dass die resonanz bis hierhin schon
sehr sehr groß ist und wir sehen dass
viele die app auch nutzen wollen aber
aus den rückmeldungen miteinander auch
lernen sie wird jeden tag jede stunde
noch besser werden übrigens auch lernen
nicht nur für deutschland sondern wir
leben ein sehr hohes europäisches und
internationales interesse auch an dem
was uns hier technologisch gelungen ist
und daraus können wir dann eben jeden
tag diese app und das was mit ihr
möglich macht möglich ist auch besser
machen
die app ist sicher sie ist freiwillig
und sie ist einfach handhabbar mehr geht
kommen vielen dank lieber jens spahn
jetzt kommen wir zu den themen
datenschutz und informationssicherheit
und ich davor seehofer das wort
übergeben
ja meine damen und herren wir sind
verantwortlich für die datensicherheit
wir haben dafür das bundesamt für
sicherheit in der
informationstechnologie und dieses bsi
war laufend in den letzten wochen bei
allen entwicklungsschritten beteiligt
und hat die app selbst und die
zugehörige infrastruktur ständig
im hinblick auf sicherheit geprüft ein
solches verfahren hat es in dieser
konsequenz noch nicht gegeben
und ich denke dieses verfahren wird auch
für die zukunft maßstäbe setzen ich kann
heute ohne jede einschränkung die
gemeinsame einschätzung des
bundesinnenministeriums und des bsi
ihnen konnten diese sicherheit und die
qualität der app ist auf einem sehr
hohen niveau und damit erfüllt die app
auch höchste ansprüche
was den datenschutz angeht ich möchte
auch darauf hinweisen dass wir im
weiteren verlauf die dinge natürlich
auch weiter verfolgen
mit den entwicklern aber auch mit apple
und google um immer auf der grundlage
neuer erkenntnisse die sicherheit der
bereitgestellten schnittstelle weiter zu
prüfen und bei bedarf zu verbessern
also wir sind sehr froh über diese
einbindung und auch über diesen befund
den ich ihnen gerade vorgetragen habe
die app leistet einen ganz ganz
wichtigen beitrag für das einmaleins der
infektions bekämpfung nämlich die
identifizierung einer infektion und dann
die unterbrechung der infektionskette
das ist eigentlich das entscheidende
wenn es darum geht eine infektion eine
epidemie oder pandemie in den griff zu
bekommen und gemeinsam mit unseren
anderen maßnahmen mund nasenschutz
abstand jene glaube ich haben wir jetzt
was die aufdeckung von infektionsketten
aber auch ihre unterbrechung betrifft
ein sehr gutes system
mir liegt es daran weil diese für mich
auch eine uraufführung war darauf
hinzuweisen dass
wir mit telekom und sap sehr gute
partner zur verfügung hatten ich habe
selten in der politik eine in einer so
kurzen zeit eine solche professionalität
erlebt wie durch die beiden firmen aber
ich möchte auch hinzufügen die fachleute
in unseren ministerien sind erstklassig
es wird nicht immer dem öffentlichen
dienst zugeschrieben dass wir da auf der
höhe der zeit sind
aber vielleicht hat es auch telekom und
sap so erlebt dass unsere mitarbeiter
hier wirklich erstklassig sind und
deshalb war es möglich nach einem
kurswechsel in diesem ganzen prozess in
wenigen wochen diese apple heute
startklar zu machen ich habe halte das
für einen großen erfolg
vielen dank das wichtigste für die
akzeptanz natürlich die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher und deswegen hat die
verbraucherschutzministerin lambrecht
letztes wort ja vielen dank sehr geehrte
damen und herren als justizministerin
beziehungsweise als managerin für den
verbraucherschutz was mir natürlich
richtig in diesem ganzen prozess darauf
zu achten dass zum einen der datenschutz
entsprechend eingehalten wird bzw
berücksichtigt wird und die
freiwilligkeit gewahrt wird
wir reden über sehr sensible rechtliche
fragen in diesem zusammenhang es geht um
die informationelle selbstbestimmung und
deswegen habe ich mich in diesem prozess
sehr gerne sehr kritisch aber auch sehr
konstruktiv eingebracht und ich bin sehr
froh dass wir eine lösung gefunden haben
jetzt heute in dieser app die genau
diese voraussetzungen auch erfüllt so
dass sich sowohl aus justiz oder aus
rechtlicher sicht als auch für
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
ausdrücklich die nutzung dieser app
empfehlen kann worum ging es ging zum
einen darum natürlich die goldenen
regeln des datenschutzes einzuhalten
also auf anonymität zu achten da rauchte
zu gewährleisten dass datensparsamkeit
eingehalten wird und ich freue mich sehr
dass der
beauftragte für den datenschutz dieser
app ein sehr gutes zeugnis ausstellt das
zeigt wie weit wir gekommen sind die
gespräche waren nicht immer einfach aber
sie waren wichtig und richtig um eben
auch die akzeptanz deutlich zu machen
die freiwilligkeit ist eine der
wesentlichen voraussetzungen dafür dass
dieser app angenommen wird deswegen war
es mir wichtig in jedem prozess eben
jedem prozessschritt darauf zu achten
dass das absolut eingehalten wird und
sie wird in zwei stufen eingehalten zum
einen entscheiden sie alle selbst
darüber ob sie diese aus meiner sicht
sehr sinnvolle app nutzen sich also auf
ihr handy aufladen und darüber hinaus
entscheiden sie dann wiederum freiwillig
was mit den daten mit den informationen
die sie gewinnen dann geschieht sie
entscheiden darüber ob sie andere
informieren
ich kann nur auffordern tun sie das denn
damit schützen sie auch andere aber es
ist eben in ihrer entscheidung wir sehen
diese doppelte freiwilligkeit ganz
wichtig bei dieser sensiblen frage
stellung jetzt gibt es die diskussion
darüber ob diese freiwilligkeit denn
auch so gelebt wird oder ob es
situationen gibt in denen womöglich
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher dann
durch die hintertür quasi genötigt
werden unfreiwillig diese app zu nutzen
in dem zusammenhang bitte ich uns alle
die lebenswirklichkeit einfach auch zu
betrachten da wird oftmals das beispiel
genannt dass ein gastwirt einem den
zugang verwehren würde wenn ich diese
app nicht nutze dann muss man sich dann
wirklich fragen warum sollte er oder sie
das denn tun denn an dem abend an dem
ich ins restaurant gehe habe ich noch
keine meldung vielleicht auf dem handy
23 tage später vielleicht schon dass ich
kontakt hatte aber was ich dann mit den
daten mache das ist in meiner
verantwortung und deswegen hat der
gastwirt überhaupt keine überhaupt keine
begründung dass von einem gast
abzufragen und deswegen bin ich der
meinung dass wir momentan keine
gesetzliche regelung brauchen um eine
solche nutzung oder unfreiwillig kite
über die hintertür auszuschließen weil
die lebenswirklichkeit überhaupt keinen
anlass dafür gibt und ich bin immer der
meinung gesetzliche regelungen machen
dann sind wenn an der fordern ist
ich sehe es in diesem fall hier nicht
und deswegen kann ich auch guten
gewissens und voller überzeugung dafür
werben
diese app zu nutzen sie schützt sie
ungeschützt andere der vielen herzlichen
dank ich habe es eingangs erwähnt dass
es ein zusammenspiel ist aus politik die
haben wir jetzt gehört wirtschaft und
wissenschaft und jetzt kommen zur
wissenschaft und ich darf herrn
professor dr wähler vom rk jedes wort
geben
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich möchte
ergänzen zu den ausführungen meiner
vorrednerin und vorredner noch einige
aspekte nennen die für uns als
herausgeber der krone auf vanek von
bedeutung sind zentral für die
bekämpfung einer jeden pandemie ist es
dass wir es schaffen die infect ketten
zu brechen und zwar möglichst rasch und
möglichst ohne ausnahmen
bislang ist es dass in einer gemeinsamen
anstrengung die sie ja alle miterlebt
haben sehr gut gelungen hier in
deutschland
ich möchte hervorheben dass das vor
allen dingen auf die hervorragende und
wirklich unverzichtbare arbeit der
gesundheitsämter zurückzuführen ist denn
denen obliegt die nachverfolgung die
infektionsketten und neben dem einhalten
der abstand und hygieneregeln und dem
tragen von alltags masken ist diese
kontakt nach verfolgung durch die
örtlichen behörden der wesentliche grund
dafür dass wir hier die pandemie in
deutschland bislang sehr gut beherrscht
haben und auch aktuell sehr gut
beherrschen können
mit dem heutigen start der korona waren
es stehen uns nur noch ein weiteres
werkzeug zur verfügung das die bereits
bekannten und bewährten methoden der
kontakt nach verfolgung ergänzen wird
mit der krone vanek können mit einer
gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit zusätzliche
risiko begegnungen aufgezeichnet werden
und identifiziert werden die bislang
durch das raster gefallen sind
das könnte gerade dann von bedeutung
sein wenn die mobilität der menschen
wieder weiter zunimmt
weiterhin ist für mich wichtig dass
ihnen aber allen auch klar ist und das
muss uns allen auch natürlich im kopf
bleiben dass die aha regel also den
abstand halten
die hygiene einhalten und die alltags
masken tragen völlig unbeschadet davon
weiterhin das grundprinzip sein muss um
die ausbreitung der pandemie weiter
eindämmen zu können jetzt zu dem
zeitpunkt wo wir vergleichsweise geringe
fallzahlen in deutschland haben wir
haben heute 378 neue fälle gemeldet wir
haben jetzt die möglichkeit uns mit der
app auch gut vertraut zu machen so dass
wir dann bei möglicherweise wieder
steigenden fallzahlen die app besser
beherrschen und wie mehrfach schon
angeregt wurde
diese app wird kontinuierlich
weiterentwickelt es ist ein lernendes
system vielleicht ein paar abschließende
worte die ich an dieser stelle auch zum
wissenschaftlichen beitrag des robert
koch instituts bei der entwicklung
dieser app sagen möchte
tatsächlich ist in sehr kurzer zeit
durch sehr intensive zusammenarbeit von
vielen verschiedenen menschen eine
entwicklung gelungen die wirklich fast
atemberaubend ist und ich möchte in dem
zusammenhang den der agilität der
leistungsbereitschaft meiner
wissenschaftler im robert-koch-institut
in hohem maße danken die eben auch seit
langer zeit sieben tage die woche mit
vielen kollegen und kollegen aus den
anderen bereichen intensiv an der
entwicklung der app gearbeitet haben auf
den ersten blick sieht man dass der app
vielleicht gar nicht an aber hinter der
benachrichtigung ob man ein geringes
oder ein erhöhtes ansteckungsrisiko hat
steckt ein sehr komplexes modell
nachdem das infektionsrisiko berechnet
wird es sind vier faktoren das eine ist
die dauer und die nähe der begegnung und
das zweite ist der zeitpunkt seit der
begegnung mit einem möglichen
risikofaktor mit einem positiv
getesteten app nutzer weiterhin spielt
der sogenannte dämpfungs wert des
bluetooth signals eine große rolle und
letztlich wird das übertragungsrisiko
des positiv getesteten app nutzers in
einem algorithmus berechnet den die
wissenschaftler des
robert-koch-instituts erarbeitet haben
gemeinsam mit den anderen an der
entwicklung beteiligten partnern werden
wir die app in den kommenden wochen und
monaten weiterentwickeln und so stetig
verbessern
danke sehr herzlichen dank herr
professor wille jetzt spricht sonst im
werk ist von der telekom ja sehr
geehrten damen und herren guten morgen
ich bin sehr froh dass wir diese app in
dieses produkt ihnen heute hier am
vorstellen können und ich möchte ihnen
eins sagen in den langjährigen
zusammenarbeit auch mit öffentlichen
projekten das ist das beste public
private partnership projekt was ich
bisher in meinem berufsleben hier
gesehen haben das ist der rockstar in
geschwindigkeit aber auch in der art wie
wir zusammengearbeitet haben alle
arbeitsmethoden waren extrem modernen
wir haben es gramm teams gehabt wir im
sprint gehabt wir haben sehr agil
gearbeitet in dem projekt war wir hatten
ja letztlich kaum zeit und die
zusammenarbeit zwischen sap und der
deutschen telekom
ja wir haben erfahrungen der
vergangenheit aber die zusammenarbeit
mit rk ii frauenhofer mit dem bsi mit
dem bmw mit dem bfd ii mit all den
ministerien arm in einer hohen
komplexität abend das zu beherrschen das
war absolut professionell und absolut
zielorientiert was da gemacht worden ist
wir haben gleichzeitig auch start-up
initiativen dabei gehabt wie zum
beispiel hashtag gesund zusammen die ja
auch etwas entwickelt haben und haben
aufbauend auf deren arbeit auch unsere
weiterentwickelt und gleichzeitig hatten
wir die komplexität mit google und mit
apple natürlich zu verhandeln weil
dieses bluetooth signal ja in den beiden
großen plattformen zur verfügung steht
und entsprechend vernünftiger messwerte
abliefern sollen
all das hat geklappt all das hat in
einem kurzen zeitraum geklappt und ich
sage ihnen auch alles ist made in
germany alles ist made in germany und
alle daten alle projekte alle cloud
liegen hier in deutschland also
deutschland kann digitalisierung aber
wenn wir alle an einem strick ziehen
das hat dieses projekt am eindrucksvoll
bewiesen
es ist aber nicht nur eine app die wir
ihnen vorstellen sondern
sie hat auch funktionen die weit darüber
hinausgehen dazu abend einige worte
erstens die technische innovationen die
diese app mitbringt es ist ja eine
abstandsmessung die wir via bluetooth an
durchführen das ist übrigens ein relativ
neues feld am mit dem wir uns am
beschäftigt haben und wir haben
natürlich in den testlaboren versucht
aus zu bekommen wie präzise oder wie
ultrapräzise die sensortechnik arbeitet
wie die kalibrierung dieses bluetooth
signals funktioniert wie die probanden
miteinander in der interaktion sind und
wir haben dieses signal kontinuierlich
gemessen und auch diese messzahlen
kontinuierlich an google und apple
zurück gespielt die daraufhin änderungen
in der art durchgeführt haben wie sie
das bluetooth signal uns zur verfügung
stellen auch hier unser dank an die
beiden großen konzerne aus dem valley am
die hier konstruktiv mitgeholfen haben
zweitens wir digitalisieren ja nicht nur
die nachverfolgung von infektionsketten
sondern wir digitalisieren ja auch an
die anbindung der testzentren und aller
labore
das heißt er heute analoge prozess wird
auch durch die korona app digitalisiert
und dadurch wird die gesamte
kommunikation indem nachverfolgen aber
auch in der information signifikant
beschleunigt wir gehen davon aus dass
gegenüber dem analogen prozess bis zu
vier tage gewonnen können und die sind
natürlich super kritisch wenn es um die
verbreitung des virus geht hier am
risiken maßnahmen durchzuführen
aktuell haben wir über 20 prozent der
großen test kapazitäten bereits
digitalisiert und angepasst wir werden
in den nächsten vier wochen alle test
labore und alle gesundheitsämter in
diesen digitalisierungsprozess
integrieren um sie am komplett von dem
analogen sehr aufwändigen manuellen
prozessen zu entlasten
bei der entwicklung der app gab es drei
maßstäbe erstens schnell fertig werden
wir sind ja wie die jungfrau zum kinde
relativ spät
prozess involviert worden und wir haben
innerhalb von 50 tagen haben wir diese
dann auf den weg gebracht zweitens die
soll ganz einfach nutzbar sein
wir haben das getestet zwischen nutzern
von 16 bis 75 jahren die mit uns
gearbeitet haben inklusive blinden
personen auch die haben wir in diesem
prozess integriert wir haben cocktail
partys veranstaltet wir haben
restaurants simuliert wir haben
schulunterricht dargestellt wir haben
zugfahrten in unseren laboren aufgebaut
und übrigens wir haben in prag in
unserem testlabor von der deutschen
telekom alle endgeräte die möglich sind
getestet und deren verhalten am
entsprechend dokumentiert vor dem
hintergrund die app ist universell sie
ist auf allen den geräten einsetzbar auf
den gängigsten handy geräten die wir
heute im markt haben nicht alle und
besonders wichtig auch an der stelle die
menschen die noch nicht die aktuellen
apple ios version geladen bitte jetzt
auch hier eine aktualisierung
durchführen weil sie voraussetzung dafür
ist dass die app dann auch entsprechend
am funktioniert wird gleichzeitig haben
wir sichergestellt dass das datenvolumen
was über das netz verteilt wird komplett
kostenlos ist
das heißt es belastet nicht das
datenvolumen das der einzelne kunde in
deutschland hat alle mobilfunkanbieter
in deutschland stelle nahm diesen dienst
kostenlos zur verfügung wir nennen das
zero rating als auch hier um keine
komplikationen sondern einfache
nutzbarkeit wir sagen gleichzeitig muss
die privatsphäre schützen
wir garantieren hundertprozentige
transparenz wir haben den quellcode und
sämtliche ergebnisse öffentlich gemacht
wir haben 7000 hinweise von der
community begibt bekommen vielen dank
auch an die community an der stelle die
sehr intensiv sich mit unserem code
auseinandergesetzt hat alles ist
freiwillig wir haben es eben schon
gehört und die app arbeitet komplett
pseudonym
das heißt sie arbeitet nicht nur im
rahmen der datenschutz grund verordnung
sondern nahm sie stellt auch zu keinem
zeitpunkt irgendeine nachverfolgbarkeit
sicher sie ist gleichzeitig hochsicher
wir haben so genannte hardcore pen tests
durchgeführt auf der app wir haben
angriffe simuliert mit entsprechenden
partnerunternehmen und sämtliche
angriffe hat das system bisher
standgehalten und gleichzeitig ist sie
leistungsstark wir haben lasst es bis zu
einem zweistelligen millionenbereich auf
der plattform getestet und alle tests
sind reibungslos verlaufen
wie geht es jetzt weiter die große frage
ist natürlich arbeiten wir an der
optimierung der app auch noch mit google
und apple
natürlich werden wir auch die ergebnisse
die wir jetzt aus dem test heraus
bekommen oder fehlers der
implementierung rausgekommen
berücksichtigen zum beispiel aktuell
gibt es intensive nachfragen ob man eine
tan braucht um die app zu installieren
an der stelle nein die brauchen sie
nicht in einer minute download ohne eine
tan kann man das am installieren die
menschen die da fragen haben können sich
aber an unsere hotline wenden auch hier
haben wir entsprechende kapazitäten
aufgebaut und menschen zu informieren
die vielleicht nicht so digital kunst
sind wie wir das sind wir wollen jetzt
auch in europa weiter arbeiten weil
natürlich menschen an gehen über die
grenzen an betriebe arbeiten über den
grenzverkehr hinaus und deswegen ist die
interoperabilität der deutschen app mit
der in europäischen apps natürlich auch
von hoher bedeutung
wir haben eine dezentrale architektur
die meisten europäischen länder haben
ebenfalls eine dezentrale architektur
wir haben unser projekt am der eu
vorgestellt hier der eu die helfer
network am instituts die sich damit
beschäftigt und wir werden in den
nächsten wochen dann sicherlich von der
eu-kommission beziehungsweise anderen
mitgliedstaaten höheren inwieweit deren
apps mit unserer app kommunizieren wird
das ist der nächste schritt an dem wir
arbeiten
vielleicht abschließend ein projekt war
es großartig spaß gemacht hat
mitarbeiten zu dürfen ich bin immer
wieder überrascht wenn man einen
gesellschaftlichen auftrag hat und eine
gesellschaftliche diskussion und die
wichtigkeit erkennt dann ist alles
möglich und die komplexität die hinter
so einer app steht in 50 tagen ich
glaube die spricht für sich und von
daher hoffe ich dass jetzt auch viele
unternehmen viele mitarbeiter viele
menschen in deutschland diese app nutzen
wir haben bereits dafür geworben dass
alle dax unternehmen entsprechend morgen
sich dazu bekennen
die app auch zu bewerben natürlich immer
auf freiwilliger basis aber auch da sind
wir gut vorangekommen
das heißt jetzt eine breite
öffentlichkeit zu nutzen bitte
installieren sie die app ich habe es
bereits installiert den herzlichen dank
lieber tim höttges und last but not
least herr dr müller von sap danke frau
ich ergänze auch noch ein paar punkte
open source hat wirklich als
stützpfeiler gedient und nur noch mal
ein paar details zu geben wir haben in
allen programmcode öffentlich zur
verfügung gestellt davor sogar die
architektur und die konzepte als open
source zur verfügung gestellt jeder
mensch auf dem planeten kann sich das
anschauen und das haben sie viele getan
wir haben über 100000 personen
verschiedene personen die sich die web
seite angeschaut haben um sich über
dieses projekt zu informieren werden 160
personen die aktiv beigetragen haben
wir haben 2000 100 meldungen bekommen
was wir potenziell noch besser machen
können was wir potenziell noch anders
machen können in form von kommentaren
und sogar 1500 ganz konkrete
veränderungsvorschläge also hier auch
ein riesen dank an die community
da kann man nicht auf eine firma oder
auf einem institut schauen das ist
wirklich es gibt ganz viele menschen die
sich damit beschäftigt haben sehr
konstruktiv und mitgeholfen haben für
alle war das denke ich ein experiment so
ein projekt auf diese art und weise
durchzuführen und wir können sagen das
hat hervorragend geklappt
es gab bisher noch nie ein öffentliches
projekt welches in welches so oft und so
offen hineingeschaut wurde indessen
transparente entwicklung noch ein paar
worte zum thema datenschutz weil das ist
wurde schon gesagt aber es ist einfach
das wichtigste thema wir haben am anfang
des projekts gesehen dass ca 50 prozent
der personen die sagen ich möchte diese
app nicht installieren sagen wird dies
aufgrund von datenschutzbedenken
ich denke wir haben alles getan was in
unserer macht steht um genau diese
bedenken aus dem weg zu räumen
und der film hat es ja auch schon
gezeigt es ist mit maximaler
datensparsamkeit gearbeitet und dann
muss man sich wirklich fragen
ok vor welchem datenmissbrauch habe ich
den angst jede pizzabestellung in jeder
online kauf jedes jede nutzung von
social media veröffentlicht mehr daten
von mir
und für diejenigen die es noch kennen
wir haben damals so verrückte sachen
gemacht wie unseren klarnamen unsere
telefonnummer und unsere adresse in
einem telefonbuch zu schreiben und das
öffentlich auszulegen
also wenn wir da mal vergleichen ob es
jetzt wirklich datenschutz bedenken
geben sollte
sagen wir ganz klar nein und das ist
eben auch von unabhängigen stellen
professionellen wir aber auch hier der
die gesellschaft konnte hineinschauen
hunderttausendfach geprüft daher bitten
wir alle diese app zu installieren
zusammenarbeit mit google und apple
dem hat es schon erwähnt auf augenhöhe
haben wir mit den entwicklern von dieser
google und apple schnittstelle
zusammengearbeitet und haben wir
natürlich haben gelernt aber wir sind
auch stolz dass wir google und apple
viel beibringen konnten um diese
schnittstelle zu verbessern und das
haben sie auch bereits getan und werden
sie in zukunft auch weiterhin machen und
davon profitieren wir dann insgesamt
global denn die pandemie ist global da
hilft ein nationales handeln nicht ganz
kurz noch was zum thema bluetooth
genauigkeit und da auch in aller
offenheit wenn sie uns vor vier wochen
gefragt hätten ob wir mit dieser app
mit dieser technologie guten gewissens
live gehen können hätten wir gesagt nein
aber wer in diesen netzen in diesen vier
wochen haben wir vor allem mit dem
fraunhofer institut sehr sehr eng
zusammengearbeitet mit dem
robert-koch-institut sehr sehr eng
zusammengearbeitet und haben diese
schnittstelle getestet ziel des tests
war die überprüfung mit welcher
genauigkeit die google und apple
schnittstelle in verschiedenen szenarien
wir haben simuliert was wir in den ic
haben simuliert so war das wie eine
schlange im supermarkt wir haben
simuliert so was wie einen
restaurantbesuch oder auch eine etwas
dynamischere cocktail party und haben
dann eben begegnen uns dauer begegnungen
des abstand von den smartphones nach
vorgaben vom rkw ganz ganz präzise
messen können und haben das mit dem das
modell vom rk ii eingespielt das
ergebnis als ergebnis lässt sich
festhalten dass bei den letzten dieser
testreihen die wir durchgeführt haben
mit verschiedenen mobilfunkgeräten in
diesen szenarien wir rund 80 prozent der
begegnung korrekt einschätzen konnten
das heißt eine person die mir nah war
über mehr als zwei meter über 15 minuten
wurde korrekt eingeschätzt und eine
person die die es nicht war wurde auch
korrekt eingeschätzt
und da professor wieder als bereits
erwähnt ja und herr minister sparen auch
wir werden ein paar personen zum testen
schicken die nicht exakt dieses in diese
anforderung erfüllt haben aber wir sind
sicher dass das die bessere wahl ist als
diese app nicht zu nutzen und wir werden
sie kontinuierlich verbessern
noch ein paar punkte zu nächsten
schritten die app ist im moment
verfügbar auf deutsch und auf englisch
die teile der hotline sind schon
verfügbar auch auf türkisch das ist uns
sehr wichtig dass die app von mit
möglichst vielen personen genutzt wird
daher werden wir als nächstes auch
türkischer sprache in der app ausrollen
und dann mit werden mit weiteren
kontinuierlichen updates eben auch
arabisch französisch russisch kommen als
weitere sprachen dann haben wir vom bsi
noch unkritisch hinweise bekommen was
wir noch besser machen können das werden
wird auch teil seien von weiteren
updates
app stores ist eine frage die auch kommt
wenn ich nicht den deutschen app store
habe sondern wenn ich zum beispiel beim
einen app store in der türkei habe dann
finden wir dafür eine lösung und wir
haben noch einen weiteren schritt in der
noch deutlicheren vertrauensbildung
bezüglich der app dass man ganz genau
sicherstellen kann dass das was wir
veröffentlichen
als open source auch ganz genau das ist
was auf dem telefon landet da gibt es
methoden für das werden wir auch in den
nächsten wochen noch machen ja daher wir
freuen uns irgendwie danken uns für das
vertrauen der politik für die wirklich
hervorragende zusammenarbeit also in
allen beteiligten ministerien instituten
und firmen wurde intensiv gearbeitet und
auf höchstem niveau gearbeitet um für
deutschland die korona waren ab heute
präsentieren zu können
vielen vielen dank herr dr müller wir
legen jetzt schon 13 wortmeldungen vor
ich würde sie vielleicht bitten dass sie
sich mit einer frage begnügen und dass
sie auch konkret immer sagen von wem sie
gerne beantwortet hätten und nicht
antworten sich dann wünschen würden und
wir fangen an mit einem blank von der
gpa ja eine frage an kanzleramts braun
verbunden mit einer frage an die telekom
es gibt heute morgen von klagen dass die
app relativ schlecht aufzufinden sei von
den nutzern und interessierten was tun
sie dagegen dass es bei apple und google
besser zu finden ist und an die telekom
können sie bitte sagen in diesem
zusammenhang hat der ausfall heute
morgen des mobilfunknetzes in teilen in
deutschland mit der app zu tun
danke die antwort ist relativ einfach
krone - ware.de das ist unsere homepage
und da gibt es auch einen direkten link
in die beiden app stores wo man sich
dann dass sowohl für ios als auch für
android herunterladen kann und wir
freuen uns dass die app jetzt da ist und
sonst wirklich freuen wenn heute sehr
sehr viele noch davon gebrauch machen
also erstmal wir haben heute morgen
schon veränderung vorgenommen wenn sie
auf ios sind sind sie sofort automatisch
auf der kola vanek drauf das ist schon
eine nummer eins gesetzt und durch die
klickzahlen die wir heute haben wir
haben schon über 100.000 nutzer ja auf
der erbse rutschen wir automatisch app
store nach oben ich glaube wir sind auch
im app store jetzt schon auf dem ersten
bildschirm oben drauf wenn sie den
anklicken dann auf apps sind wir schon
jetzt auf nummer eins arbeiter sind wir
auch daran dass sie sofort eben unsere
äpfel haben
die zweite frage wir hatten heute nacht
am eine ausfall in unserer infrastruktur
am das licht damit zusammen dass wir
gerade aktiv das netz umbauen
sie wissen dass wir vor dem 5 lonza in
deutschland stehen und daher werden wir
an dem netz viel umbauen den nächsten
wochen und monaten
da ist es heute nacht zu einem ausfall
gekommen dafür entschuldige ich mich
wenn kunden davon betroffen sein sollten
seit heute morgen laufen alle arm
infrastrukturen wieder reibungslos bei
der deutschen telekom
und das hat nichts mit der woche damit
der gewinner werden zu tun
nächste frage frau ludwig von der sz
eine frage von lambrecht zusagten die
bedenken geäußert werden haben mit der
lebenswelt nichts zu tun die bedenken
sind aber ja auch dass arbeitnehmer vom
arbeitgeber verpflichtet werden können
die app zu benutzen wie sehen sie das
und ich hätte noch eine frage an herrn
wieder und zwar diese 15 minuten
warum genau wurde dieser zeitraum
gewählt die frage ob arbeitgeber
arbeitnehmer zur nutzung der app
verpflichten könnten die wenn überhaupt
stellt sie sich nur in bezug auf die
nutzung von diensthandys weil ich habe
keine möglichkeit als arbeitgeber zu
verpflichten ein privates handy zu
nutzen oder mir diese app aufzuspielen
bei der nutzung eines diensthandys da
ist zu berücksichtigen dass ein
arbeitgeber ein weisungsrecht gegen dem
arbeitnehmer hat aber bei dieser weisung
die unterschiedlichen interessen auch
abgewogen werden müssen das ist
rechtsprechung des brg und dabei spielt
zum einen natürlich die frage des
infektionsschutz es im betrieb eine
rolle aber auf der anderen seite eben
auch das was wir ausdrücklich
feststellen dass es freiwillig sein muss
die nutzung dieser app und diese beiden
güter die müssen gegeneinander abgewogen
werden könnte ich würde einschätzen dass
aufgrund der ausdrücklichen
freiwilligkeit und der anderen
möglichkeiten die ich als arbeitgeber ja
auch habe infektionsschutz im
unternehmen zu gewährleisten
überwiegt hier ausdrücklich diese
freiwilligkeit meine einschätzung denn
ein arbeitgeber hat selbstverständlich
andere möglichkeiten über erfassung von
kontakten schriftlichen erfassungen von
kontakten diesen infektionsschutz denn
darum geht es ja zu gewährleisten
ja die 15 minuten und der abstand das
sind die regeln die wir seit anfang der
pandemie empfehlen da gibt es zwei
erklärungen das eine ist es gibt
umfängliche untersuchungen die schon vor
längerer zeit gemacht wurden unabhängig
von dieser pandemie wie sich menschen
verhalten wie lange menschen zeit
miteinander verbringen und da hat man
ganz klar heraus gefunden dass
engere kontakte da sind 15 minuten so
eine bestimmte schnittstelle wo man
sieht dass danach der kontakt enger
bleibt das heißt also das ist eine zahl
die einfach mitten sozialverhalten
zusammenhängen das sind daten die
hauptsächlich in europa erhoben wo und
weshalb wir das nach wie vor für sie
relevant halten und der zweite aspekt
ist der dass wir davon ausgehen dass
eben die übertragungs wahrscheinlichkeit
steigt weil einfach durch die
tröpfcheninfektion die eine große rolle
spielen und auch die aerosole
das ist eine gewisse zeit benötigt bis
man wahrscheinlich genügend virus
aufgenommen hat das heißt das risiko
steigt einfach mit längerer zeit und das
sind die zwei parameter aus denen sich
zu 15 minuten ergeben jetzt herr schuler
von der bild wenn ich daran anschließen
darf die app wäre also missinterpretiert
wenn man sie so verstehen würde dass man
weniger als 15 minuten durchaus sehr
nahe zusammen sein kann
also es sind beide parameter einzuhalten
und da ich hier noch eine technische
frage dass mein bluetooth ständig an ist
kann ich jetzt bei fangen opfer von
irgendwelchen hotspots werden an denen
ich vorbei laufe und mehr werbung auf
spielt oder eingelesen werden
ja zur ersten frage die präzision ist
natürlich nicht genau auf den zentimeter
das ist glashütten range den die app ist
quasi also diese identifikations codes
die ausgetauscht werden es gibt eine
untere grenze alles was unter dieser
grenze ist also etwas unter diesen 15
minuten es wird eben gar nicht erfasst
und alles was dann halt auch eine
bestimmte entfernung unter etwa drei
meter hat das wird auch überhaupt nicht
erfasst das heißt also es wird ein
ranger erfassung erst wenn der wenn der
ausreicht dann wird überhaupt eine
identifikations code ausgetauscht und
auf dem eigenen handy dann geladen von
einem anderen handy aber die zur anderen
faktoren die man noch die ja noch da mit
reinspielen es geht ja mal darum dass
wir einen risiko ski ermitteln das wird
das ergebnis sein was dem app nutzer
dann auf gespielt wird hat er ein
geringeres risiko
skoda hat er einen höheren risiko dass
er in der nähe einer person war die
positiv getestet wurden die person muss
muss positiv getestet worden seien und
daher nutzten relativ komplexen
algorithmus dieser algorithmus den
konnten wir auch erst eigentlich in den
letzten wochen programmieren
der algorithmus hängt damit zusammen wie
wirklich die infektionsepidemiologie der
krone also der coop 19 erkrankung ist da
geht also ein
wie lange ist die inkubationszeit wann
ist die höchste infektiosität der person
wie lange dauert es in der regel bis
menschen positiv getestet werden das
testergebnis mitteilen also alle diese
daten
die konnten wir erst in den letzten
wochen wirklich erheben denn die gab es
ja vor der pandemie sowieso nicht wie
kann das virus nicht und wir wissen ja
wo es seit wenigen wochen genau die
verteilung der krankheits schwere der
ausscheidung der infektiosität das heißt
also all das alle diese faktoren diese
vier faktoren ich anfangs nannte gehen
in die bewertung ein bis dahin ein
nutzer der app einen risikos score
mitgeteilt bekommt und was er letztlich
mitgeteilt bekommt ist doch steht drin
und es bezieht sich immer nur auf die
letzten 14 tage also wenn 14 tage länger
als 14 tage alle diese identifikations
kurz werden vom handy gelöscht was er
mitgeteilt bekommt ist er hatte so und
so viel risiko begegnungen mit demselben
handy von dieser person und die letzte
risiko begegnung lag so und zu vier tage
zurück das sind die einzigen
informationen die die person erhält die
einen erhöhten risikos korea erhalten
wird also ein recht komplexes modell
aber wenn ich richtig informiert bin ist
auch open und naja ich glaube ich diese
ganzen informationen das schöne
algorithmus wo wir so hart daran
gearbeitet haben auch der ist einsehbar
trotzdem hat der herr schuler in der ihm
eigenen art gefragt und deswegen will
ich ausdrücklich sagen ja die antwort
auf ihre frage ist ja natürlich kann
auch jemand der unter 15 minuten kontakt
hatte infiziert werden
wir mussten halt nur mit anderen
arbeiten wenn sie sehr intensiven
kontakt mit jemand anderem haben auf
welche art of man kann's auch in
sekunden passieren vielleicht dass sie
jetzt den eindruck vermitteln man müsste
immer nur 15 minuten um die frage
präzise zu beantworten ja
gerne zum thema rot also was passiert
auf den mobilfunkgeräten dass das alle
zweieinhalb bis fünf minuten
zufallszahlen versendet werden über
einen zeitintervall von vier sekunden
werden 16 mal wird dieselbe zufall sei
versendet diese zufall zahl ändert sich
alle zehn bis 20 minuten
das macht es möglich eine person zu
tracken in ein gerät zu tracken und das
zweite serie gefahr kann jetzt damit
schindluder getrieben werden können sie
werbung bekommen oder ähnlich ist das
ist nicht möglich weil sich diese zu
fallzahl sehr zügig ändert und b keine
identifikation und keinen rückschluss
möglich ist von dieser zufall zahl auf
ihr gerät und auch nicht von dieser
zufall zahl auf sie als person dann für
quadbeck von der rheinischen post
ich würde gerne wissen ob es vorgaben
gibt wann ärzte dann tatsächlich testen
sollten sie sagten ja gerade es gibt
hohe oder niedrige risiken die mir die
wahl anmelden kann
ab welchem risiko sollte der arzt dann
den test machen und noch eine
klitzekleine frage nach zahlen der sie
beantworten kann
wie viel prozent der bevölkerung haben
denn ein handy das die korona app
überhaupt laden kann personen über 16
jahre
das ist im grunde die kategorie eins
also im grunde betragen wir das aus der
analogen welt auch in die digitale
werden wir heute kontaktpersonen der
kategorie 1 das sind die berühmten
gerade schon diskutierten 15 minuten und
eine gewisse nähe und wer eben diese
entsprechende risikoeinschätzung bekommt
also hohes risiko kann sich testen
lassen wir doch aufgefordert oder
eingeladen sich zu melden beim
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst oder beim
hausarzt oder bei 11 6 11 7
das ist ja die 24 stunden 7 tage hotline
auch der kassenärztlichen versorgung und
wir haben sicher gestellt sowohl durch
unsere verordnung wie durch eine
abrechnungs ziffer dass sowohl die ärzte
wie der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
einen entsprechenden test daneben auch
refinanziert bekommen dass also das ist
ja auch die neue qualität auch für st
um lose kontaktpersonen damit im grunde
die möglichkeit zur testung besteht das
war ja bis jetzt auch nicht durchgängig
so und wären durch die korona waren app
gesagt bekommt da er war ein
entsprechendes risiko oder ist ein
entsprechendes risiko kann damit
entweder beim öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst oder beim arzt und
immer telefonisch vorher kontaktieren
dann die entsprechende testung bekommen
und sie wird übernommen
also wir haben in deutschland wenn man
von der grundgesamtheit von 80 millionen
einwohner hat geht 65 prozent der
bevölkerung die heute ein smartphone
nutzen können das sind über 50 millionen
smartphones die wehr im einsatz haben
gleichzeitig kommt es aber gar nicht auf
die größe an derjenigen die das dann
auch installieren sondern jede einzelne
installierte app hilft um die
verbreitung des virus zu reduzieren und
für die menschen haben die momentan noch
kein smartphone haben wie die deutsche
telekom ab sofort in ihren shops extra
handys an auch für ältere menschen
einfach zu installieren und wir helfen
auch den menschen diese app in unseren
shops als gemeinsam mit unseren service
leute installiert zu bekommen gut dein
herr größten park vom spiegel
mich würde interessieren wer in diesem
system design eigentlich den überblick
hat
ob es positive tradings gab und wann das
erste erfolgt ist das habe ich noch
nicht ganz verstanden das müsste ja
eigentlich wieder dann der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst maximal sein
sind die denn angewiesen dass zu melden
sie werden ja auch ein interesse haben
an erfolgsmeldungen wer hat eigentlich
diesen überblick das habe ich nicht
verstanden und die zweite kurze frage
noch diese 80 prozent in den tests in
denen das ansteckungsrisiko richtig
berechnet worden ist verstehe ich das
richtig interpretiere ich das wichtigste
das heißt 20 prozent gefahr von false
positives und force negativs
also zuerst einmal das ist ja normal
dass wenn sie es dezentral machen hat
niemand den abschließenden überblick
schlicht und ergreifend das war genau
die debatte die wir die letzten wochen
miteinander geführt haben dass durch
eine dezentrale
lösung gebe nirgendwo die daten
zusammengeführt werden wir werden
möglicherweise sehen wer sich bei den
hotlines meldet das ist ja dann klar wer
anruft
aber ansonsten ist das eben dezentral
freiwillig so dominiert was die frage
angeht ich ja schon wieder vergessen hat
die 80 prozent ja der kann zu der
messtechnik nochmals aber ich will auch
dann noch mal einfach das sagen was ich
vorhin gesagt hab lieber einmal zu viel
testen als einmal zu wenig wir erwischen
jetzt nicht den der 50 meter weg war
sondern es ist sozusagen eine range um
die es da geht aber ich mir sehr wichtig
dabei zu sagen hier geht es ja dann um
eine information die ist ein möglich
macht risikoverhalten für sich
anzupassen und vor allem einen test zu
kriegen und dann finde ich ist das in
der prozentualen zuordnung die sie
beschreiben mehr als verantwortbar
vor allem im vergleich übrigens zur
heutigen gedächtnisprotokolle war heute
ruft das gesundheits- und sie an wenn
jemand gesagt hat ich war vielleicht mit
dem in den letzten zwei wochen in dem
kontext ich bin mir aber nicht mehr ganz
sicher
und ich würde tippen dass da manche
trefferquote deutlich unter 80 prozent
ist doch mal was zu den 80 prozent sagen
was bedeutet das wir haben nehmen wir
ein einfaches beispiel von 100 personen
einigen davon wären nah dran gewesen und
andere werden nicht mehr angewiesen
haben wir in diesem test 80 prozent
richtig identifiziert das bedeutet 20
prozent waren entweder nah an mir dran
über einen zeitraum länger als 15
minuten und wir haben sie nicht
identifiziert über bluetooth messung
oder sie waren weiter weg wie gesagt das
sind keine 50 meter sondern er
vielleicht sind es hat drei meter
gewesen
ähnlich ist und wir würden trotzdem
diesen personen eine nachricht geben
dass sie sich testen lassen sollen und
wir veröffentlichen auch in den nächsten
wochen noch mehr details zu den tests
die wir dadurch geführt haben um da auch
einfach dem versprechen der transparenz
weiterhin treu zu bleiben und wir haben
auch immer gesagt diese app wird nicht
masken
pflicht und abstand ersetzen das ist zum
beispiel jetzt ein sehr gutes beispiel
das leben 80 prozent erkennt und 20
prozent eben nicht und darunter sind
auch personen die nah dran waren die
aber jetzt nicht erkannt wurden daher
müssen wir weiterhin auch die sehr gute
arbeit und stelle gesundheitsämter der
ärzte der labore weiterhin
aufrechterhalten
frage an herrn sparen er hat gesagt eben
erwähnt in vier wochen sollen alle
labore möglichst digital angebunden sein
bedeutet das dass dann das man
eigentlich nicht mehr diese hotline mit
der telekom braucht wo ja die
mitarbeiter nach bestem wissen und
gewissen rauskriegen sollen hat jemanden
positiven test und zweite frage haben
sie denn schon mal in den app-stores
geschaut wie bisher in den ersten
stunden die abrufzahlen zu den app
stores können die knapp 100000 wir
gerade schon für android war es schon
erwähnt
ich sitze gerade kann nicht schauen aber
davon so der zu der frage der labore ist
das jetzt eine anstrengung wenn höttges
und aller sich einig sind dass das jetzt
gelingt den nächsten vier wochen dann
gehen wir auch davon aus dass das
gelingt indem anschluss an die
anschlussstelle pure digital
das sind sehr viele labore deswegen ist
es auch wichtig übrigens auch in den
informationen die wir parallel aber das
ist noch mal ein ganz eigenes feld
machen gerade im verhältnis öffentlicher
gesundheitsdienst labore unter der
überschrift dem ist also das system das
wir generell mit dem
robert-koch-institut in der meldekette
gerade erarbeiten
und ja es ist eine richtige einschätzung
das umso mehr labore digital angebunden
sind und umso mehr möglich ist über die
schnittstelle dann ein qr code
zugänglich zu machen
direkt desto weniger die hotline
gebraucht werden wird ob sich dann jeder
am ende weg über eine hotline erübrigt
oder nicht wird man dann sehen aber ihre
sozusagen ihre zahlenmäßige bedeutung
wird dann
möglicherweise zügig zurück gehen können
und damit übrigens auch natürlich das
finanzvolumen dass wir möglicherweise
dann zur aufrechterhaltung der hotline
brauchen weil die betriebskosten im
monatlichen in nicht geringem umfang wir
natürlich mit einer 24 stunden 7 tage
hotline die auch auf eine gewisse
nutzerzahl erstmal angelegt ist
zusammenhängen mit jedem labor das
zusätzlich angeschlossen wird reduziert
sich sozusagen das was bei der hotline
passiert wir haben aktuell auf android
zwischen 100 und 500 tausend nutzer bei
apple etwas wissen wir dass nicht das
ist mir mit denen diskutieren das werden
wir aber noch an erfahrungen was mich
besonders freut ist sowohl auf ios als
auch auf android haben wir kunden
bewertung von 47 48 sternen
das heißt also fast das den vollen
punktzahl wenn sie das scoring kennen
wissen sie dass das ein absoluter
spitzenwert ist jetzt trinke von reuters
die frage geht an den braun unternehmen
sparen
herr wieder hatte eben schon die
niedrigen relativ niedrigen fallzahlen
im moment erwähnt deswegen meine frage
wie sehr zielt diese entwicklung der app
und die perfektionierung auf eine
mögliche zweite welle
rechnen sie mit der das dann die app
voll verfügbar und voll entwickelt sein
soll dank sie dient ja vor allem der
vermeidung einer zweiten welle also
genauso wie die tägliche arbeit die
wichtige der gesundheitsämter die gerade
schon erwähnt worden ist jeden tag
infektionsgeschehen nachzuvollziehen
lokale ausbrüche einzudämmen
infektionskette zu unterbrechen
genau diesem ziel dient wie abstand wie
gene alltags maske diesem ziel dient
dient auch diese app genau diesem ziel
eben ein nicht mehr koordiniert
vollziehbare dynamisches
infektionsgeschehen zu vermeiden das ist
ja genau die situation in der wir waren
im märz und die wollen wir eben für die
zukunft vermeiden und der leiste ist da
ist die app einen wichtigen beitrag dazu
vor allem das will ich auch noch mal
sagen zu einem zeitpunkt wo die zahl
niedrig sind ja aber wir gleichzeitig
eben im öffentlichen leben im der
mobilität zu flug bus s bahn
demonstration habe ich schon
angesprochen auch bei derlei
gelegenheiten
wir sind immer mehr in kontakt ja kommen
wieder mit personen die wir nicht
persönlich kennen und kontakt
nachverfolgung klassischer art durch die
befragung wen haben sie denn die letzten
zwei wochen getroffen mit wem man sie
intensiven kontakt kann nicht
funktionieren bei dem zug nachbarn den
ich im zweifel einmal meinem leben und
nie wiedersehe
und da macht diese app gerade in dieser
phase der lockerung in der wir jetzt
sind um mit dem zunehmender mobilität
dann nochmal einen wichtigen unterschied
und da kann ich noch ergänzen wir haben
ja festgestellt dass es sehr viel
leichter ist infektionszahlen niedrig zu
halten als sie von einem hohen stand
wieder runter zu kämpfen und deshalb ist
das zentrale ziel was wir haben
eben nicht wieder eine hohe
infektionsgefahr mick zuzulassen und
sagen wir der reigen der maßnahmen die
dafür dafür haben sind diese lokalen
beschränkungen das also werden lokal ein
größeres ereignis auftritt dann sehr
schnell lokal reagiert wird damit nicht
sozusagen bundesweite beschränkungen
erforderlich werden
dazu gehört eben die gute personelle
ausstattung des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes vor ort um die
manuelle kontakt nachverfolgung schnell
und vollständig hinzukriegen
aber diese app lohnt sich vom ersten tag
an das eine das ist schon erwähnt worden
das ist ihr beschleunigungs effekt also
wenn ich eine infektion vermeiden möchte
dann muss derjenige der sich angesteckt
hat das ja am besten erfahren bevor er
selber merkt dass er krank ist
weil dann zieht er sich vielleicht aus
anderen gründen schon zurück dann ist
der zusatznutzen den die app bringt eher
gering
das heißt es muss schnell gehen als wir
am anfang uns entschieden haben
diese app zu machen hatte ich ehrlich
gesagt an die anbindung der laboren noch
überhaupt nicht gedacht aber das ist ein
ganz zentrales element dieser app weil
dadurch ich dieses testergebnis so
schnell erfahre und dann so schnell den
kontakten melden kann dass wir da
wirklich zwei bis vier tage sparen
können und das sind eigentlich die alles
entscheidenden zwei bis vier tage das
heißt wir hoffen dass wir genau in den
fällen durch die app es schaffen
wirklich infektionsketten frühzeitiger
zu unterbrechen und das ist etwas was
sozusagen auch bei den niedrigen
fallzahlen jetzt eine rolle spielt und
der zweite punkt ist wenn heute
nachmittag jemand in im zug sitzen in
jemanden den er nicht kennt der in zwei
tagen hat sich als positiv heraus stellt
und er geht frühzeitig in quarantäne und
steckt niemanden mehr an dann hat sie
sozusagen ihren wert unmittelbar auch
jetzt und in einem fall sozusagen einer
zusätzlichen dynamik würde natürlich der
effekt eskalieren
aber da wir ja
festgestellt haben dass wir unser ziel
haben die infektionszahlen niedrig zu
halten ist sie auch ab sofort ein
absoluter gewinn und deshalb ist unsere
hoffnung dass die leute diese app
vertrauen schenken und sie ab sofort
einsetzen sie arbeitet ja im hintergrund
sie stört mich in meinem alltag 0 sie
muss nur eben geöffnet die
nachverfolgung eingestellt werden und
dann kann man sie eigentlich vergessen
sie arbeitet im hintergrund muss man
immer nur meine noch wieder gucken ob
sie noch da ist aber sie ist eigentlich
kein aufwand im verhältnis wirklich zu
der großen wirkung die wir uns davon war
der pandemie bekämpfung erhoffen
es soll mit blick auf die uhr kann ich
leider maximal noch zwei kolleginnen und
kollegen dran nehmen herr ziegler von
der stuttgarter zeitung
es liegt jetzt an ihnen ob noch jemand
dann die chance hat eine große
verantwortung im verhältnis ohne die
minister sparen und braunen oder
vielleicht auch herr wieder frage jetzt
zu den nutzungszahlen oder ab wann es
wirklich helfen kann ist sehr
verständlich dass jetzt keine konkrete
zahl nennen wollen es kursieren ja aber
diesen studien dieser 60 prozent die
schon als falsch oder nicht als weisheit
letzter schluss land wurde aber eben
auch die 15 prozent also vielleicht
könnten sie doch stellung dazu nehmen ab
wann ist wirklich gut funktioniert oder
noch oder richtig auch gesellschaftlich
richtig viel bringt diese zahl und eine
frage nach hinten oder auch im
zusammenhang mit nutzungszahlen warum
sollten die jugendlichen ausgeschlossen
werden
so war es zu lesen dass die sich das
nicht runterladen können dürfen
vielleicht erstmals der oxford studie
wir haben uns sehr genau angeguckt der
gedanke der 60 prozent war eigentlich
für den fall dass eben nicht das
eingebettet ist wie es hier vorgestellt
haben sondern dass sie dass das zentrale
instrument zur pandemie bekämpfung ist
so verstehen wird es hier nicht sondern
es ist ein baustein neben allen anderen
und auch die autoren der studie haben
sowohl im text als auch jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit deutlich gemacht dass
natürlich das einen skaleneffekte ist je
mehr leute mitmachen desto besser
deshalb fordern wir auch alle auf der
app vertrauen zu schenken mitzumachen
und sie freiwillig zu nutzen sagen
gleichzeitig dazu dass wir jede art von
konditionierung und zwang nicht dulden
wollen und das td ich glaube dass also
sozusagen eine untere schwelle nicht
wirklich sinn ergibt weil an dem
beispiel bahn kommen wir wieder zeigen
wenn es schon mal alle nutzen und auch
wenn das nur ein kleiner teil der
bevölkerung ist die regelmäßig bahn
fahren und zug fahren sie also mit
leuten halt zusammen kommen die
hauptsächlich anonym sind dann ist das
ein riesen wert im verhältnis zu
jemanden der irgendwie bei sich zu hause
arbeitet und den ganzen tag immer nur
die gleich drei gleichen kern trifft dir
gut kennt dem müssen dann nicht so
zwingend erreichen der dem empfehlen wir
es auch weil man manchmal gar nicht
merkt wie viele leute man doch eben
trifft die man gar nicht so richtig
wahrnimmt aber grundsätzlich geht es
erstmal um diese zentralen gruppen und
deshalb gibt es aus unserer sicht keine
mindest erfolgs grenze sondern jeder der
mitmacht ist gut so viele wie möglich
und am besten natürlich alle
ich finde sehr wichtig für kollege
braungart gar immer gefragt wenn nach
diesen 60 prozent das ist unter der
annahme dass keine anderen maßnahmen
getroffen werden keine maß keine
öffentliche gesundheitsämter die
arbeiten keine was weiß ich was und es
deswegen muss man diese 60 prozent aus
der welt schaffen
jeden tag verständlicherweise gefragt
werden aber ich glaube ich einfach
nochmal richtig zu sehen diese studie
gehen davon aus meinte nur die app und
sonst gar nichts dann sind wir wieder
bei solchen zahlen zur einwilligung das
ist übrigens bei jeder app so für
minderjährige dass ohne die genehmigung
der eltern
jedenfalls die dinge nicht einfach so
runterladen sind im realen leben glaube
ich wird sich das mit der genehmigung
der eltern dann alles ergeben wie bei
anderen apps auch aber das ist eben der
hintergrund auf den datenschutz zu recht
auch wert legt man muss ja einwilligungs
fähig sein
das haben heute schon sehr viele eltern
sich gemeldet die gesagt haben sie ihren
kindern vor der schule noch runter
geladen das problem ist eher dass an
vielen schulen ein handyverbot besteht
dass vielleicht ein thema was in dem
zusammenhang noch mehr zu diskutieren
ist allerletzte frage frau du den von
epc eine frage geht an
gesundheitsminister sparen in welchen
abständen wollen sie bilanz ziehen und
wie transparent werden sie das tun mit
den transparenten ansatz den wir
gemeinsam in den letzten wochen bei der
entwicklung der app gewählt haben mit
dem wir das ist glaube ich auch deutlich
geworden für ein solches projekt auch
maßstäbe haben setzen können sowohl beim
open source ansatz wie bei der frage
datenschutzkonzept bei der frage
epidemiologischen konzept als er alles
öffentlich und zugänglich und
nachvollziehbar
diesen transparenten ansatz wir
natürlich auch fortsetzen auch in der
frage der weiterentwicklung der app in
allen bereichen und soweit es eben das
war ja gerade schon eine frage wie sehr
kann man denn eigentlich nachvollziehen
wie weit ist zum beispiel zur positiv
testung kommen so weit es möglich ist
mit einem dezentralen freiwilligen
anonymisierten konzept überhaupt daten
auswertungen zu machen werden wir sie
natürlich transparent machen
aber es liegt in der natur der sache
wenn sie einen solchen freiwilligen
einsatz werden wir wie ein richtiger
weise gewählt haben das dann eben nicht
die daten auswertungen möglich sind die
dann manche sich erwarten übrigens
häufig dieselben die sagen das muss
freiwillig und anonym sein wollen
anschließend aber möglichst umfassende
daten darüber haben
was denn alles passiert ist beides
gleichzeitig geht nicht ich darf ihnen
jetzt ganz herzlich im namen der
bundesregierung für ihr interesse danken
vielleicht noch zwei organisatorische
hinweise
wir sehen es noch einen werbespot
sozusagen für die korona waren app und
sie haben dann anschließend noch die
möglichkeit und ich darf alle
podiumsteilnehmer einladen draußen noch
ein gruppenfoto machen zu können
natürlich mit dem gebührenden abstand
ihnen erst mal vielen dank und für die
fragen die noch nicht beantwortet wurden
stehen sicherlich alle teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer wollte auch noch
bilateral zur verfügung herzlichen dank
du bist mal hier mal hier mal da und ich
bin immer bei dir ich weiß nichts über
dich aber ich beschütze dich und sag
bescheid wenn es ernst wird
ich bin sicher und ich kann helfen
infektionskette zu unterbrechen aber ich
bin nicht ohne dich wer ich bin ich bin
nie corona waren app und ich brauch dich
dich dich und dich gemeinsam bekämpfen
der korona bist du dabei ticona vanek
jetzt herunterladen alle informationen
unter corona web.de und ich bitte jetzt
alle auch mit abstand nach draußen zu
gehen